super-hearing is a tough business one
minute you're choking around punching
bad guys in the face and the next you're
pushing up fictional daisies fortunately
when you've got superpowers there's more
than a decent chance you'll be
resurrected and given new life usually
because you're more valuable to your
parent company alive than dead
well any of these super people come back
to life in 2018 or beyond probably but
for now let's pay our respects and mourn
their super passings
and of course spoilers ahead Logan and
Professor X in a year filled with so
many superhero flicks it's hard to
believe that the r-rated Wolverines swan
song Logan actually hit theaters in 2017
but it did and it was basically a
superhero slaughter fest in addition to
the demise of Caliban the d-lister
mutant who was played by comedian
Stephen Merchant Logan gave the final
send-off to two characters who've been
thrilling comic book fans of the movies
for nearly 20 years Professor X played
by Sir Patrick Stewart met an inglorious
end at the hands of an evil Wolverine
clone but not before he practically
stole the show in the movie that was
named for a totally different character
but it was the loss of Logan himself
played by fan favourite Hugh Jackman
that fans will remember for years to
come Jackman's held the role of
Wolverine since 2000 original x-men
movie and his portrayal is rightly
lauded by helping make superhero movies
the force of nature that they've become
given the chance to take the character
out on his own terms
Jackman helps fans say goodbye to Logan
at the movies end in a beautiful moment
that stands out is not just one of the
most classic moments in a superhero
movie but one of 27 teens best movie
moments period Patriot Jeffrey Maysoon
the comics is better known by his
alter-ego the Patriot debuted on ABC's
agents of shield in the fall of 2016
the character played by Jason O'Mara was
revealed to be the new director of the
super spy agency and at first his name
felt more like an easter egg
a nod to longtime comics readers that
the show's producers were reaching far
into Marvel's back catalogue for new
characters to play in their small corner
of the MCU as time went on we learned a
whole lot more about the TV version of
mace he was supposedly an inhuman who
uses enhanced strength and
invulnerability for the greater good but
as it happened this was all bogus mace
had no powers and instead took the
television equivalent of super steroids
sort of like crapped in America
[Music]
when the show came back in 2017 after
its midseason break Mason the rest of
the shield team found themselves on the
framework a VR simulation where Hydra
ran the world and the good guys were in
hiding their mace heroically sacrifice
himself to save his fellow agents from
doom it was a fitting end for the
character who in the span of only one
season had quickly become a favorite of
fans of the show
Black Widow in the 2016 Marvel Comics
event civil war - an inhuman who can see
the future shares a vision with Marvel's
superheroes in it Miles Morales stands
in the steps of the US Capitol his
costumes soaked in blood clutching
Captain America's lifeless body it's a
provocative image and yet it took a
while to get more information then all
the heroes got pretty busy when Captain
America revealed that he was actually a
Hydra sleeper agent took over shield and
conquer the United States man talk about
a real craft in America in the follow-up
Marvel Comics event story secret Empire
miles and Steve Rogers met face to face
but neither of them counted on Natasha
while cap and spider-man squared off at
a secret Empire number 7 the Black Widow
had already been watching in a nearby
roof with a sniper rifle hoping to end
Captain America's reign with a single
bullet when the fight broke out Black
Widow intervened hoping to save
spider-man unfortunately Captain
America's shield broke Natasha's neck
and she didn't survive once the story
was over and finished the Cosmic Cube
undid all of evil caption Anakin's a
black widow stayed underground her
funeral took place in secret Empire
number 10 of course since she's played
by one of the biggest movie stars on the
planet the chances of her staying that
way for long are basically slim to none
the widow will be back in comics pages
soon count on it the Warriors 3 in Thor
Ragnarok Thor saves most of the
Asgardians from hella goddess of the
underworld with help from Hulk Valkyrie
and Loki to name a few he doesn't rescue
everyone however the warriors 3 Thor's
rambunctious sidekicks fight in the
front lines when hella attacks none of
them survived the film their defeats are
so quick in fact that Marvel Studios
President Kevin Feige actually had to
explain that the warriors 3 needed to
get decimated to show how big a threat
hella was it worked but Thor's corner of
the MCU is poor for it Martin Stein any
legends of tomorrow fan who is
paying attention knew that dr. Martin
Stein better known as firestorms older
half was on the way out in October right
before legends returned for its third
season deadline announced that actor
Victor Garber who plays Stein would be
leaving the show so he could replace
david Hyde Pierce and Broadway's Hello
Dolly revival soon after the news broke
legends started planting the seeds for
Garber's departure Stein was working on
a way to separate himself from Jefferson
Jackson the young man with whom emerges
to create the super heroic firestorm too
bad Nazis show up to spoil the fun in a
plotline too complicated to adequately
recap here Stein is shot and separated
from firestorm dying after having saved
his friends in the process hello dolly
goodbye dr. Stein yondu udonta the first
guardians of the galaxy movie introduced
the world at large to Peter Quill's
abductor the Craigie drawling Ravager
who taught star-lord everything he knows
about conniving and swiping stuff was
also a wizard with that deadly whistle
II arrow thingy comic book fans on the
other hand know he was a core member of
the original guardians of the galaxy
team yondu got his start in the first
appearance of the team in Marvel
superheroes number 18 in 1969 so has
turned to the site of good in guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 and his heroic
sacrifice to save his adopted son Peter
made the loss all the more memorable my
movies end his Ravager funeral just
before the film's credits stands out as
one of the most touching moments we've
seen in the MCU yet perhaps most
importantly he managed to make Mary
Poppins cool again like Mary Poppins
is he cool hell yeah he's cool for
Disney Marvel's corporate parent that's
called vertical integration and
corporate synergy and that's the most
heroic act of all thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our youtube channel let's check out all
this other cool stuff we know you love
to
[Music]